we're looking at estimating
probabilities and this is one of the
most important parts of all of this
probability stuff like we want to
understand a situation and then use that
understanding to forecast and say I
think this is going to happen
I can plan for this because I have a
sense of what the future should bring so
here's a situation where they've done
some analysis of families and how many
female children are in each of these
families okay so we have a frequency
breakdown here
okay now in order to work out
probabilities from this what we need to
do is take each of these and turn them
into a fraction which divides by your
total sample space now in this case we
can add up all of these to get a total
has anyone already done that and worked
out how many there is if you add up all
of those go ahead punch it in 143 is
what I got as well okay very good
so what we are calculating just to sort
of refresh your memory from the past few
years of thinking about this probability
what we're now going to do is relative
frequency right so how frequently do
these occur relative to all the other
things that are existing in this
situation relative frequency and another
name for that in this context is what we
call experimental probability it's not
theoretical it's not like what should
happen it's like we didn't experiment
this is what actually happens so if you
want to write that down just as a bit of
a hook for you experimental probability
is another name for this same idea okay
so there's a couple of things I want to
draw out here right the first one is
just to do this calculation from the
start we just take our frequency divided
by how many people there are there right
so in each case it's going to be this
number like 15 divided by 143 that's how
many people are there yeah then it's
going to be this number 55 divided by
the same 143 okay we'll go all the way
down and this is what we get now you'll
notice me leaving a bit of space over
there on the right-hand side of that
cell the reason why is that often we
will state these probabilities will
state these relative frequencies in some
kind of decimal or percentage form okay
which requires us to round off now
pounding off is June usually fine but
sometimes a particular spots you have to
be careful for instance go ahead and if
you're in a oK we've got a row of four
key role for I'm gonna make you guys you
guys can work out to each and then I'll
make you guys sort of a group of 4/5 I
need you to each calculate one of these
right I want you to calculate what these
are and I need you to get the whole
calculator display there so that's why
I'm getting you to get different numbers
so that you don't have to round it off
in your head or anything like that so
you know work out who's calculating what
15 over 143 55 over 143 and so on right
now so so just we hit equals I just want
the number there for a second okay now
you don't need to write this down but I
am gonna ask you guys to help me
note this who worked out 15 on 143 who
wrecked it out okay good
can you just give it to me to one
decimal place zero point one okay you
don't need to write this down I'm just
gonna take note of it who did 55
everyone forty three words yet zero
point zero point four sixty two over 143
who worked it out no one way that it's
zero point four as well that's fine
that's okay
and who got the last 111 on 143 also
zero point one now just have a look at
this with me okay when you add up in a
discrete random variable when you add up
all of your probabilities what are you
supposed to get one right now if you
have a look at this hopefully it doesn't
like you don't need to do your
calculator that adds up to one right so
if I so good but watch this this is
where I want you to be very careful
right and I picked this very
deliberately this time I do want you to
write down not one not two I need you to
write down I got here no I do want hold
on and make sure I get the right number
yeah three three decimal places can you
write down these numbers not to one or
two decimals but to exactly three okay
can someone tell me what the first one
is zero point one 104 105 105 I want
three decimal places okay next one zero
point
three eight five three eight five yep to
be great next one zero point four three
four are we sure on the rounding on that
one
four three four someone else want to
verify as well thanks to mark and last
one eleven on one forty three point zero
seven seven okay very good
now this time we're all gonna do the
same calculation and you're delighted
right these ones here with three decimal
places key and these ones up point one
at five point three eight five point
four three four point zero seven seven
what is that it up - no it doesn't what
I calculated beforehand was one point
zero zero one right now we knew what it
was supposed to add up to right and in
fact rounding doesn't automatically
cause problems right sometimes it's fine
and in fact if I check this before when
you do to decimal places also fine you
four decimal places also fine it just
kind of depends on where it is that you
cut off the decimal so you do have to be
really careful with this fractions are
precise can you see this one 143 that's
why our fractions are really gross and
kind of difficult to write in decimal
form so the fractions are going to be
exact but often you will have this issue
so just watch out for okay there's the
first thing the second thing is I wanted
to compare this to theoretical
probability right so what should we
actually expect to happen if this is
what new didn't happen what would it be
if we had boys and girls being equal
chance okay now for this situation here
I'm just going to make an assumption
which is completely unfair but we want
to simplify this a little bit let's
assume all these homies had three
children okay
what would we expect if we just kind of
guessed in calculations didn't do any
experiment what would we expect each of
the probabilities to be how would we
even go about answering such a question
think back we've talked about like a
good three four five tools that we had
for thinking about different situations
and how to calculate probabilities on
them we talked about lists
we talked about arrays I talked about
tables which tool do you think might be
most helpful when we're thinking about
three children that are either a boy and
ago a tree diagram is definitely going
to be the most helpful okay now if we
just really rough and dirty over here on
the side here we've got a little space
we're doing a three charges so we're
going to need three sets of branches
right so we're gonna have something like
this yeah I think I'll just fit okay so
each time boy your boy y'all can you go
ahead key draw this with me boy okay
now this does show me the situation but
in fact what I'm really interested in is
what's the total number of female
children at the end of it after all
three children have been born so when
you have a look at the top how many
female children have you bought on this
particular series minutes that's the
zero right so zero female next one down
one next one down look carefully
dude it's it's one right there next one
next one girl boy boy that's one this
one here - next one - next one okay very
good
now if we can assume which is pretty
close not exactly but if we can't assume
that boys and girls are equally likely
right what should the probability of
each of these ones on the end be if
they're all equally likely how many how
many what's the size of the sample space
how many events are there
eight and we assuming they're all
equally likely so it's one over 8 1 over
8 what about do you agree right another
way you could calculate that is 1/2
times 1/2 times 1/2 still give you 1
over 8 right but notice that we're sort
of skewed right like what's the chance
that there's 0 female there's only one
way you can get that right but when we
think about how many chances are there
of there being one female child there's
many of them right how many 3 ways three
ways that I can get a single female
child so those 3 up like that become 3
out of 8 for a single female child what
about where you're going to yep I need
another color here so again it's 3 out
of 8 and then the last one chance of
getting 3 this is 1 mm right and we can
know we did it right because if you go
ahead and you calculate it's all adding
up to 1 so how does that compare to what
actually happened
have a look where's my arm radar how did
I compare to our actual probabilities
are they within a reasonable range maybe
you help us to get these in decimal form
so we can compare them as anyone know
what 1/8 is in decimal 0.125 0.375 0.375
0.125 does it fit within what we
actually expected it's pretty reasonable
right it's a it's not far off so I'm
pretty happy with our experiment mostly
matching reality so now ah oh yeah
question what do you mean oh I see okay
like well if I wanted an answer for that
I would have to give you some specific
sort of like parameters for that because
maybe actually if you had an actual
demographer and they were answering that
they'd say that's crazy like this is
really shows this is a weird population
or something like that I don't have
actual specific information and the
question would have to provide that to
you because we don't expect your whole
experts on analyzing populations and
that kind of thing so we can leave that
to one side if that's okay
now here's my last question right how
can we use this to write at the top
their estimate the probability of
something happening for instance if we
had say 2000 families
2000 families like well I mean not ever
there's lots of siblings in Chariton or
high school but let's just call the 2000
right how many of them would you expect
off of this to have no girls in the
family if you had 2000 now if we use
this theoretical probability we'd get a
number but we have the experiment right
we have the experiments you would take
this relative frequency yeah question
yes that's true that's true so this data
is female-centric but that's fine every
data is sort of centered on some
particular aspect and that's okay
I'm going to take this number 15 out of
143 and how does that connect to the
2000 I multiplied yeah
multiply that by 2000 can someone tell
me what we get I'm guessing 200m yeah
hundred nine I was guessing 210 but I
was rounding off in my head right so we
expect that number of families on the
basis of our experiment to be able to
have this number and this is hugely
important it's usually important for
like family planning for like have a
look at um you know how many people are
taking the metro how many people taking
the metro yeah most no less really come
on people we live in Cherbourg right
they had to work out the size of that
car park how do you think they did that
there were you know that I was I walked
into that one they were using the
probabilities of how many people are
taking public transport and so on so
this is what exercise six and eight a
and a B go into further okay